hi I'm Ryan and I'm David and we're
reviewing trailer number two for the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles now this is
full trailer number two I think there
might have been a teaser before that um
just up front I said to David as soon as
this trailer was over if I was 13 years
old this trailer would blow my mind yeah
it's definitely action heavy and we this
trailer definitely stands out we see a
lot of shredder yeah splinter - it's
very nicely put together trailer in my
opinion I think the color palette is
great too I mean everything is it's very
sort of high tech you know we're clearly
in the modern age this isn't 1985
anymore
it's almost old fashioned and as much as
it's like Oh oversaturated this hip
right there is this very like even
though I video spots for a second so one
of the Navy Turtles kills a fleshlight I
disagree with you I don't think that
that's all so they're using guns in this
and I remember correctly in the other
Ninja Turtles movies we don't see guns
like I want to get the exact frame going
so keep talking Dave so I think that's
Donatello the wall so that yard Oh
Leonardo and you go through a window he
is through window safely onto the Sun
west that's at least 10 concussions no
there's been a lot of work done in New
York the subways are very safe now he
was saving that guy Rhodey Jionni proves
so throughout this they're doing very
cheesy voiceover you know felt like this
is our city I do like this this beat
though I mean maybe Fox love her or hate
her she's in the movie just your stupid
epithet now they look like giant Shrek
monster no we are getting like more
context for these scenes that we've seen
previous trailers um again I can't get
behind this part of the list of their
faces I also am a little freaked out by
how giant they are yeah again they're
supposed to be ninjas it's not but
they're breaking things there's a
teenage maiden football turtles that's
true but they are playing up the humor
kind of like especially with
Michelangelo obviously he's kind of the
jokester the bit the skateboard yes they
love skateboarding in the other movies
too
see this is the like there are things in
this that are like remnants of the early
nineties where's just like skateboarding
school right
I mean skateboarding is cool but like in
a different way now we see some exotic
locale look house we got rid of some
sort of a winter wonderland yeah
Donatello they really I mean Donatello
is the inventor of the bunch they kind
of they seem to be playing him more as
like a geeky like nerdy guy we're in the
previous ones he's just really smart in
kind of his own dude they're they're
really playing up like the he's almost
like deta
yeah Goonies I think this is definitely
Ninja Turtles on steroids because
physically they are on steroids and all
their personality traits are yeah and
even the armor of shredder here you know
this massive if you've seen secret of
the use you know about super shredder
yeah at the end of the movie and that
looks like super shredder we still don't
know if it's supposed to be William
Fichtner in there yeah I read somewhere
it could be a robot
yeah and we also don't really know the
true size because splinter can be very
small yeah that could be a three-foot
rat or like a viper rat tony shalhoub
does the voice of a splinter I'm really
interested to see what the snow thing is
one I was worried because turtles are
cold-blooded that might that might be an
issue oh he says okay so Raphael says we
have to go get my brothers back also I'm
wondering if splinter just got killed
here like are they revealing that in the
here's here's the line he says let's go
save my brothers so that implies that
and if you look closely in these these
snow scenes you don't see Raphael so it
seems like in the movie he gets
separated which is kind of a running
theme in the Ninja Turtles because if
you remember from the original 1991 the
very first version Raphael gets
kidnapped and they have to go get him or
he gets kind of separated and beaten up
and they have to go save him so they use
dubstep dubstep to modernize this team
yeah a rocket-powered skateboard
bazookas I mean
like I feel like dubstep is like the
modern-day version of what they would
use is like surf rock yeah and you know
what I think it works if they're going
for an audience of like teenage teenage
kids and I think that this really like
speaks to that I'm more excited to see
the movie now than I was after the last
trailer oh yeah and the motion capture
like the there's no much more detail in
these Ninja Turtles I think than the
last trailer let's talk about this
they say that they're not we're not
aliens because the controversy on the
web for a long time was that the Ninja
Turtles were gonna come from a planet of
turtles and they were aliens and we were
alien Turtles and my goodness did the
blogosphere ever have it out on that one
so yeah this is by far the best thing
we've seen from this movie um um I'm
excited David I know that you're excited
yeah I'm gonna see this movie two things
that we learned from this trailer of you
David is going to see this movie and he
knows that Megan Fox is in the movie
she's in the movie I don't know I'm
gonna say some lines so yeah I mean I
think that if there are naysayers about
this movie I think they are becoming
less and less as more material comes out
but let us know what you think I might
be completely wrong comment below and
let me know say Ryan you're wrong and
then you know other mean things about me
please don't I'm just kidding um yes
comment below we want to know what you
think until next time I'm right I'm
David thank you for watching